десятки тисяч полеглих і покалічених
воїнів з обох боків тисячі загиблих
цивільних українських громадян
незліченна кількість зруйнованих міст в
Україні до цього можна додати глобальний
дефіцит енергоносіїв інфляцію та голоду
багатьох країнах що розвиваються це
наслідки війни яка і через рік після
початку досі не завершилася президент
Росії Володимир Путін не зміг досягти
своєї мети повністю захопити Україну
однак Росія окупувала приблизно 5
частину країни президент України
Володимир Зеленський натомість
неодноразово заявляв що всі окуповані
Росією територією включно з Кримом
будуть відвойовані
у військовому плані українцям вдалося
дещо відтіснити росіян вони звільнили
понад 50% території яку росіяни
окупували ще в лютому адже За різними
оцінками під час бойових дій було вбито
або поранено близько 200 тисяч
російських солдатів і ці цифри схожі
зростають дуже високими темпами Протягом
останнього місяця коли російські війська
кидають людей хвилі за хвилею в атаку
навколо бахмута
Україна зможе звільнити ще більше своїх
територій вважає американський експерт
Чарльз cupchan старший експерт Ради з
міжнародних відносин проте можливість
повернення всіх окупованих територій
України експерт пов'язує з можливою
подальшою ескалацією
Я вважаю що Україна зможе повернути
більше території але є ймовірність того
що ми побачимо таку собі патову ситуацію
замість повного відновлення
територіального суверенітету України Я
також вважаю що зусилля України
повернути Крим силою насправді значно
підвищать ризики ескалації як
територіальної тобто ширшої війни так і
вертикальної ескалації можливого
використання Росією ядерної зброї
останнім часом здавалося що ядерна
риторика Кремля пішла на спад але
останні раптове рішення Кремля
призупинити важливий договір щодо
контролю за ядерною зброєю шокувало
західних експертів з озброєнь після
початку повномасштабної війни низка
країн НАТО та ЄС ввели санкції проти
Росії Утім санкції не мали такого
сильного впливу на російську економіку
як очікувалося вважає Стівен пайфер
експосол США в Україні експерт академії
Роберта боша тим не менше експерт
переконаний вплив від санкцій на
російську економіку ставатиме дедалі
відчутнішим як і подальша ізоляція Росії
геополітична подивіться що сталося
Швеція та Фінляндія дві країни які мали
давні традиції нейтралітету зараз
прагнуть і подали заявку на вступ до
НАТО Отже коли я дивлюся на цю війну то
думаю що врешті-решт це стало
катастрофою для Росії Володимир пу Тін
його его настільки прив'язане до цієї
війни що Кремлю важко шукати
альтернативний курс
чи вдасться Україні перемогти Росією у
військовому плані залежатиме від того
якою буде подальше військова підтримка
України західними партнерами переконаний
Штефан майстер з німецького товариства
зовнішньою політики адже На його думку
Росія все ще має достатньо сильної
економіки щоб інвестувати у війну в
найближчі два-три роки
Росію Можна було б перемогти у суто
військовому сенсі тобто вигнати її з
України Якби захід справді втрутився
військовим шляхом Я думаю що тоді Росія
була переможена те як зараз здійснюється
підтримка західних країн в тому числі і
розвідувальними даними недостатньо для
того щоб Україна виграла цю війну і
вигнала Росію зі своєї території Я
вважаю що зараз Важливо щоб Україна не
програла війну і відвоювала деякі
території але того що дають західні
партнери У підсумку недостатньо
наразі Україна отримала від західних
партнерів лише чверть від обіцяного
останніми місяцями озброєння в Україні
наголошують що Західна зброя необхідна
вже зараз аби суттєво змінити ситуацію
на полі бою це дасть українським
військовим насамперед можливість
впевнено воювати в наступній кілька
місяців знаючи що будуть надходження
західної зброї яка компенсує будь-які
втрати яких українська армія може
зазнати в найближчі два-три місяці це не
дасть їм Я думаю дуже потужні можливості
танки Абрамс танки Леопард дуже
ефективні і Це дало б українцям Я вважаю
розширено здатність проводити Контр
наступи щоб вибити російську армію з
території України Це все зброя але що
насправді стане вирішальним фактором Так
це рішучість мужність майстерність та
новаторство українських військових і
вони вже це показали протягом останнього
року
закінчення війни не військовим шляхом а
шляхом мирних переговорів найближчим
часом експерти оцінюють скептично адже
наразі обидві сторони вірять у можливий
прогрес на полі
боюнський
білий
вдалося досить успішно переконати
союзників по нату не просто продовжувати
поставки зброї а й підвищити їхній
рівень тож поки що я думаю щоби її
будуть продовжуватись Я вважаю що десь
протягом 2023 року можливо наприкінці
літа чи Восени ми дійдемо до моменту
Коли Україна та Росія можуть вирішити що
вони не в змозі досягти подальшого
прогресу на полі бою і саме в цей момент
я думаю дипломатія зможе досягти певного
прогресу як може виглядати якесь
дипломатичне врегулювання дуже важко
сказати Я думаю що одним з елементів
цього буде рішення України прийняти
нейтралітет озброєний нейтралітет тому
що ми бачимо як НАТО озброю є Україну
аби Росія не могла досягти успіху і
ніколи не спробувала напасти знову
зараз було б розумніше надати Україні
більше зброї надати Україні такі
інструменти щоб Україна змогла або
відтіснити росіян найближчим часом або
досягти достатнього прогресу на полі бою
і щоб Кремль вирішив що він має ввести
серйозні переговори але я кажу про
переговори які могли б привести до
врегулювання на умовах які Україна могла
прийняти
експерти переконані швидкого закінчення
війни не буде а подальше зміна ситуації
на полі бою залежатиме насамперед від
військової підтримки західних партнерів